good afternoon everyone thank you so
much for coming uh my name is Liz roten
I'm a data scientist and I am here to
make the argument that there is an i in
team and um there and some peer-to-peer
best practices for growing data science
teams so in the
beginning I was in um I started at my
organization the Metropolitan Council in
St Paul Minnesota we're a regional
governing
body um and when I started we had a very
tiny data science team and by tiny I
mean a total of two people um we did not
really work with each other our projects
were totally separate um but we had the
great experience at least my manager did
of proving to the rest of the
organization that data science was
valuable and the great work that we did
proved it we had some turnover over time
but we also were able to expand to and
you know evangelize a bit about our
Version Control GitHub Etc and more
people started using data science
tools but it was really clear that we
were all used to working in our own
little
Bubbles and this became very clear with
something I'll call the incident
so how bad was this
incident back in the beginning I wrote
an r package for the council but
actually it wasn't really for the
council I was the only one using it so
it was just for me and I got to do
whatever I wanted with it it was great
um it's called
counselor made a
logo um it has things like uh corporate
colors database connections templates
classic internal r package um and as we
got more people on board using R using
GitHub I got more people to install the
package and start actually using it for
themselves which was a really amazing
feeling um at some point I decided that
we should just completely rehaul the way
that fonts were sized and our plot 2
theme which is fine but it had some
unintended side effects so I wrote this
update pushed it out had all my
colleagues install it it
installed which I considered a win um
however my colleague installed the
update while they were working on a very
time-sensitive report and for any of you
that have worked with going from armar
down to my Microsoft Word there is
a there's a lot of potential frustration
there with
plots
so the thing is that what I did didn't
break their code it just changed
things so if we see this plot where we
have my plot plus theme Council um where
the font sizes are correct the title is
one of the largest fonts that you see
you can read the X and Y AIS um as well
as the legend title the axis titles all
of it makes makes sense and the caption
is Tiny like it should
be but then without breaking the code so
there was no like warning or like clear
this didn't work um the plot did this
where the caption is massive um the text
on the X and Y axis is practically
non-existent the legend title is Tiny
the title title font is different and
the y-axis title is
rotated and this isn't none of these are
bad but when you're trying to get
something going uh it's not fun when
something changes right underneath
you so what went wrong there were
several things um first there was
inaccurate and in inadequate
documentation on my part um there was
also a lack of communication so I didn't
adequately convey the changes I was
making to my colleague and so they
didn't know what to
expect and we also had mismatch
priorities I was having fun tinkering
with my package and my colleague
actually had something to get out into
the world so that
conflicted and the next question is
could my manager have prevented
this and the answer is no my manager
could not have prevented this um this is
an interpersonal team
thing and that's where my argument comes
in there is an i in team because teams
are groups of individuals working
together
notee I in
individuals and you as an individual
team member can shape your team by
caring for your new team members and
your current team members seeing how you
fit into your
team sorry could you grab my water
bottle
please thank
you
seeing how you fit into your team and
changing how you
work and as the turnover has happened at
my job and we' brought more people on
board there are a few things I've
learned that I'd like to share with you
today and one is that when you have a
new colleague coming on board it's your
responsibility to bring them on board
too
it's not just HR it's not just your
manager it's it's you as
well so when you're bringing on a new
teammate three things make the implicit
explicit all knowledge is valid and
valuable and document also known as make
life easier for your
friends so first make the implicit
explicit the story here is um from a
commencement speech by a fairly famous
American writer um in which there are a
couple fish swimming around and in this
instance we'll say that these are you
and your
coworker having a great time being fish
a new fish comes along and then they ask
a fairly innocuous question how's the
water to which there's
silence and then what the hell is water
and now you need to understand that this
fish is having a crisis they don't know
what they've been living in their entire
life um what does it mean to be
surrounded by this thing constantly all
the time and why am I just now being
told that there's water so this fish is
having a
struggle and you don't need to be an
anxious fish don't deny that water EX
exists and by water I mean your
workplace
culture everyone has pet peeves and
preferences every workplace and every
team within a workplace has a culture
and that's not inherently
bad but you need to recognize it for
what it is and because because otherwise
when a new person comes in you're giving
them the task of proving that like oh no
there is a culture here in addition to
figuring out if they want to stay on the
team don't give your new coworker the
task of defining what water is in
addition to evaluating if the water is
right for
them there are a few ways you can Define
your water and these are just a couple
starting
questions what does your weekly schedule
look like how much time do you spend in
big meetings one-on-one meetings really
deep focused time what does it look like
for you
you what tools do you use every day why
and I mean every single piece of
anything that you touch throughout the
entire day make a list and how do you
use
it and what expectations does your work
group have around email or message
response times same thing goes with
having a status indicator in your
Microsoft teams or slack um as well as
any after hours communication expect
ations the second all knowledge is valid
and
valuable no one is an empty vessel and
so all of the knowledge that this new
person is bringing to your team is
valuable no matter where they're coming
from if they're coming from a different
industry coming straight from college
coming straight from an online course
wherever they're coming from the
knowledge that they have
is useful and even if it seems very
unrelated for whatever reason in my
workplace we've attracted a lot of PhD
ecologists which is not what we do um
and I've learned so much from
them you also have to remember that your
knowledge is not inherently Superior
just because you've been at this
workplace
longer so when you're bringing this new
colleague in it's important to give them
some
Grace patients will prove best whether
you're introducing them to a new tool
integrating them into the broader
organization and getting all those
social relationships sorted out whatever
it is have patience and it will pay
off and remember that you're also on
probation um in my workplace you are
hired you have a six-month period
whether and at the end of that the the
employer can decide whether to keep you
and they're on probation but you as a
team member are also on probation
they're figuring out if they want to
work with you and that's important
too also don't rely on catchall
assumptions ask for
specifics for example someone two people
who have git and GitHub on their resumé
but have very different ways of working
with Git will have different experiences
someone who's on the command line is
going to have a very different
experience than someone like me who
relies on a really nice user interface
to visualize
branches neither of these are
necessarily better than the other
one but you need to ask for those
specifics rather than
assuming and finally document AKA make
life easier for your friends
so an experience you may have had at
breakfast this morning not in this hotel
but whenever you had breakfast is if you
were to have
cereal which comes first the cereal or
the
milk and there are all sorts of answers
there's also questions like why cereal
what kind of cereal should it be sugary
organic whole grain what kind of cereal
and then what kind of milk should it be
milk milk what kind of cow milk what
kind of not cow milk there are all sorts
of ways and I'm going to be truthfully
brutal with you guys it doesn't
matter what does matter is that you
remember the
bowl in which to put your cereal and
milk documentation is the bowl data
science is an incredibly creative fields
which is one reason why I enjoy working
in data science there are many ways to
solve a problem and by trying to force
everyone into One Singular way you're
not taking advantage of all of the gifts
and knowledge that they have to
bring embrace the diversity of opinion
and
experience even if it's hard for you as
the existing person or and it will be
hard for the new person coming
in just remember remember whenever
you're going through something to leave
a trail for others to follow add in
comments in your code every few lines
try to tell leave a trail of breadcrumbs
towards the final outcome or whatever
process documentation is also a matter
of investment you're investing in tools
that encourage documentation and lower
the cognitive load uh you're also
investing in the time that it takes to
document clean up organize Etc your your
work and you're investing in strong
social
relationships this might not seem very
intuitive but follow
me documentation is communication in
written form and for good communication
you need to know your audience kind of
like if you're giving a talk at a
conference so this means that work
doesn't always feel like
work schedule time to build connections
and Trust in-person virtual hybrid all
of the
above social Gatherings and virtual or
in person are just as valuable as that
coveted like afternoon hours of focus
really and it took me a while to kind of
accept that
and try making every other team meeting
a casual hangout that's something that
we've done in my work group um we have a
weekly team meeting and one week we talk
about work the next week we talk about
not work and I've gotten to know my
colleagues so much more and have gained
a better perspective of who they are as
people and the backgrounds that they
have my colleagues are really great
they're really interesting people and I
enjoy working with them
ultimately at the end of the day there
is an i in
team several eyes teams are made up of
individuals and it's not only the
manager's job to make the team work it's
your responsibility as a team member as
well onboarding is a unique and critical
time when someone is coming in and you
can take advantage of that time to gain
a really great relationship with them
and set them up for success in your
workplace I've grown immensely from
working with my colleagues um and that
isn't really because I have a great
manager um my manager is pretty great
but it's because of the time that we've
invested in each other as a team and not
because my manager waves a magic wand
and makes everything
work thank you
thank you so much Liz we'll have time
for some questions
um so how would you all of these
recommendations that you've made how
would you pitch those to management
because it even though it's I it needs
some broader support right um this
particularly um I
think uh particularly in like scheduling
hangout time um if you can start by
pitching it small so like we're going to
do a 15minute coffee break particularly
when Co started and we all started
working virtually um just having a popup
15 30 minute coffee break is permissible
like that seems okay and you kind of
work your way up because you you find
Value and you build you prove the point
as to why that little 15 minutes is
worthwhile and then maybe the next time
you ask it's like how about a lunch or a
secret lunch and learn that is learning
about your new colleagues and not about
databases or something um and you can
work your way up
um fantastic thank you so much thanks
again Liz thank
you